Oh for crying out loud why am I not
surprised
[Music]
Sheriff's Department we just said that
what do you guys what do you think I'm
not letting you in I didn't like open
the door knock knock who's there
Department we have a warrant this time
let us end okay hold on it's gonna go
the kitchen for a second okay okay open
the door first please Terry open them
bond or good lady at that house over
there okay looking out her window seeing
Wow what did you say can you describe
partying for me please I go yeah mm-hmm
and I got my flute mm-hmm
Terry can I ask you a question but is
that flute another man's penis whoa no
time and no timeouts in black and white
well maybe the football okay now we're
I'm not gonna sitting here waiting for
my girlfriend to pick me out you're
waiting for your girlfriend to pick you
up
what's your girlfriend's name again to
see me see me spelled F e-e-e e-e-e-e am
silent J what's going on yeah I don't
know the five of my girl why are you
guys always harassing him
Wow your congratulations I got this that
lowered of the wedding ring beautiful
demonstrate one of the stars you're
expecting oh my god
by Terry Terry put his wiener we did it
with them artificial and somewhere just
yeah because he has a condition now so
we don't actually Oh room we get to the
bedroom we get nude and then I can't get
hard and I vomit okay okay okay